قبل دقائق اعلنت هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه اخر حصيله رسميه وبلغت 76
شخص يقومهم وحوالي 440 شخصا مصابا هذه
الحصيره الرسميه لكن اعتقد ان الارقام
اكبر بكثير لان فرق الانقاذ ما زالت تحاول
الوصول الى العالقين تحت الانقراض لكن
نتعاطى الان مع الحصيله الرسميه التي
تحدثت عن سته او التي تتحدث عن 76 شخصا
كما ذكرت اعتقد ان الحصيله اكبر من ذلك
لان فرق الانقاذ ما زالت تواصل الوصول الى
او تحاول الوصول الى المناطق المتضرره
نتحدث عن عشره ولايات
تضررت او هناك ابراك في عشره ولايات
تقريبا
غازي عنتاب بكل العثمانيه اضن وايضا
باضافه الى طبعا كهرمان مرعش وغازي عنتاب
هذه اتيت الرئيس كل هذه الولايات فيها
دمار في عدد من المباني وهناك اشخاص
عالريقين تحت الالقاب لذلك نتوقع ان
الحصيده ستكون اكبر من الحصيله الرسميه
التي اعلنتها هيئه الطوارئ والكوارث
التركيه افاد